[Music]
[Music]
all right calling a calling Mike Mike V
to the set to the set I heard someone in
the interview call you Mike like this
she owned or something
you didn't even bother to correct of
your sight whatever I'm in Omaha this is
the oh this is so adorable look at us
all right
you ready for this yeah my yeah looks
like we're both there all right here we
go
hot breath averse welcome back to the
hot breath podcast this is your weekly
guide to comedy mastery I am your host
comedian Joel Byers and our guest today
not only a master of comedy writing but
also a master of the discipline it
requires to become a professional
comedian this guy start comedy way back
in 2000 with a master's of special ed he
was also teaching while pursuing
stand-up comedy three years into his
comedy career cashes in his retirement
moves to New York the rest is history
his whole journey has taken him from
doing I believe it was bagged puppet
jokes yet still time to now doing things
like just Jay Leno Comedy Central
half-hour special Jimmy Fallon his own
podcast no disrespect and now the hot
breath podcast yeah it's big it's a big
I really appreciate you doing your
research Joel yes for this and I felt
like as you should if can you dub rocky
music in the background yeah we're gonna
add that get me in a towel maybe doing
some push-ups yeah I think it's great
yeah well welcome aboard I know you like
to workout too so thanks for that guy
worked out today and then you were like
let's do this in Lobby I'm like why
don't you just come up to the room it's
very romantic I think the last person I
had in a room I may have it Andrew
Schultz or Nick Griffin we didn't trust
either of those guys wouldn't trust
either of them all New York hustlers
yeah you know that's that's where you
kind of cut your teeth is in that that
gritty New York scene well what do those
guys have to say cuz I'll go the exact
opposite of everything that they said
every every ounce of advice they get I'm
doing the opposite card write jokes
don't work at all it'll come to you when
you get on stage that's your secret the
states that now that's I do the opposite
I prepare jokes and try them yeah you're
very meticulous that's why I'm such a
fan of you is because you are one of
these craftsmen that is like particular
it seems
about word choice and the the arc of a
joke and you're really mindful about
like the craft behind stand-up right
because I don't want to go up there and
I don't know my thing is to go out there
with a plan okay and then put it on tape
or evaluate it and then try to keep
working the joke until it until it comes
so even if it's not funny enough like
maybe I lose it or come back to it you
know it's all up it's all a process but
if it's not funny enough like you can't
keep it even if you really like it you
know how many times will you try it
before you have to scrap it if I really
like it I'll try it or not and then I'll
talk about it with somebody I'll be like
look at this I think this is funny this
is not working and they'll be like well
maybe adjust this or adjust that or try
this or try that and then I'll try it
and then chances are it'll probably work
with it wouldn't while making it some
adjustments to it there's something
funny there our instincts are very
rarely wrong there's like you know it's
something very funny here and it's not
working then it's like okay you need to
either set it up differently or
something word positioning it needs to
be a little too from it in a different
way but yeah you need to keep working it
so you should never back off your
instinct if you're like this is funny
yeah and it's not working then just keep
working it I haven't heard someone say
that before where though they'll try it
on Oh Andrew and Nick didn't cover that
guess this is the best one everybody
already the best you ignore the others
exactly but then go back and like and
subscribe and like them they're my deer
for all of those guys and very town
writing both of them they're
unbelievable so when you're when a joke
isn't working you actually work shopping
at offstage with with someone in
conversation yeah I mean I should do it
I should do that more than I do it but
yeah that piece of advice that's like
this does work but I don't do it enough
I don't do it enough yeah the two things
I don't do enough are listening to tape
back and making the corrections and the
other thing I don't do is I do it but I
don't do it enough is talk it out with a
with a
comic-like offstage combination what do
you think of this and then what do you
think of this and back and forth it
really does help so what what do you
normally do how do you normally work out
Joe I'll just for a while I was
journaling cuz I felt like my act I
started to feel like a joke machine for
a while like I'll just joke joke joke
and nothing was that personal and and so
I started journaling in order to correct
that now since then I was like okay now
I have deeply personal stuff that I'm
trying to make a joke so now it's like
focus on tweaking it into a joke you
know I mean that's the other thing so
free writing in a journal is good to
make things more personal but also then
then you know minimizing it and working
on the jokes is important to not getting
to like big with you know just like a
narrative it's like okay none of this is
some of this is getting some laughs but
it's not funny enough like it's not fun
enough so it's like okay now I have to
go back and look at each detail and see
if I can get a joke out of each thing so
to really focus on it what do you mean
not getting too big with the narrative
well some people like you wanna the guys
I really like even if they're
storytellers like they have it punched
up all the way through like they're
hitting you know there's not this long
set up and to a payoff like it's punched
up all the way through so if you have a
story like that and you like oh this is
a good there's something good here then
it's about going back and then finding
the jokes within the story and then and
then you know having to lose stuff if
it's like oh this isn't good this isn't
working
this isn't funny enough I think we some
people like we hesitate to do that
sometimes cuz we're like no no this is
fun it's like it's just not funny enough
I can't keep it you know so it's it's
hurts to do that sometimes cuz you're
like no no this is funny you'll you'll
fight yourself you'll defend it
but at the end of the day after enough
times of it getting a soft laugh like
this is not funny enough and it's not
necessary for the joke I'm just used to
saying it you know my mind is
conditioned to saying it and that's why
I have this attachment to it but it's
not
necessary and it's not helping do you
find what it can help with editing is to
like revisit the premise of the joke
like okay what am I trying to say here
and that can help you to kind of trim
off those soft laughs it's not so much
what you're trying to say it's it's you
know what you're trying to say but it's
like is it is it working is in hitting
so it's maybe it's like oh maybe the
punch line this is too harsh maybe I
need to frame it differently frame it in
terms of like softening it you know look
if you're gonna tell a pedophile joke
I'm telling a pedophile joke you soften
it by saying pedophilia is not funny
guys but jokes about pedophilia some
jokes about pedophilia are funny and I'm
gonna attempt that now all right you
know I mean like something like I don't
know because it's a topic where if you
just rip into it people are gonna be
like ah right no but but if you and they
still might do that but at least like
you're framing it a little bit and
softening it but you're doing it in a
funny clever way where it's like you
could still get into the joke and you're
kind of bracing them for it a little bit
you know when you're exploring a topic
do you have a percentage like over your
years of experience is there like a
certain amount of jokes you have to try
and then you like one out of twenty you
end up keeping or is there like it's
something like that it's a lot yeah it's
it's a ratio it's like the more you
throw the more the higher percentage
you're gonna you're gonna keep yeah and
that's just anything that's like that's
just the way it is like the more you try
and the more attempts that you make the
more success that you're gonna have and
getting rid of the weaker jokes opens up
slots for the stronger jokes to appear
as well as yeah and it's also there's a
thing to like I really want to talk
about this it's like okay well if you
really want to talk about it you've got
to find the jokes in there you can't
talk about something I understand people
really want to talk about stuff but yeah
it's got to be strong enough to be in
your act like it can't be weak or maybe
it can be and then you work it into
something strong but you can't just
leave it week and go yeah this is what I
want to talk about it's like yeah this
isn't a TED talk there this is right you
need laughs in there and either talk
about it effectively or get rid of it I
have
doing that now I have a bedbug try to
talk about bedbugs because I had them
and it really was a major influence on
my life because it ruined it ruined me
for a while that was like right when you
moved to New York wasn't it and I was a
I had just I was about I had to give up
my apartment I was about seven years in
though I didn't give up my apartment
because of it but I was attacked and
then I would get an exterminator would
come and exterminate and then I thought
I was safe I put everything back you'd
have to you have to clean everything
push everything to this end of the room
wrap it in plastic it's really crazy
frosting do you still leave stuff in
your bathtub when you're in hotels yeah
I mean I have nothing close to my bed
underwear laid out there where I'll
sleep in that and then I'll wrap it in
plastic at the end of the trip and bring
it home and wash it immediately and
we'll take it out of plastic like it's
made up reporter yeah yeah a profound
effect on my life so well anyway my
point is I have one good bedbug joke and
it's like I have other ideas for jokes
but nothing is strong enough to take
right now so hmm it's like okay what's
the next thing you know it's like keep
coming with it but you know I could keep
trying but right now the reality of it
is I only have one good joke so how do
you start to add more jokes around a
single topic with Thomas's what's you
know there's a lot of stuff that
happened during that time exterminators
coming exterminators going my
relationship with my landlord the
bedbugs themselves attacking me and the
way that they procreate it's called
traumatic insemination in the male bed
it's really something the remember my
Jam's his penis into the female bedbug
stomach and that's how he gets her
pregnant and she has a vagina there's no
reason he can't just have sex with her
vagina but he doesn't he just puts it in
their stomach and then the it's not
funny no that's not funny and I'll tell
you what's that's not even the worst
thing the worst thing is a male bedbug
will penetrate an another male bedbugs
stomach and shoot his sperm into the
other male bedbug then the other male
bedbug will have sex with a female
bedbug and get her pregnant with the
rapist bedbug sperm so that's what I'm
dealing with
Wow I know why it's so traumatic now
it's traumatic insemination all those
late-night Google session
learning that stuff it's crazy they're
not good insects they're not good so to
get back to the joke about this
traumatic experience well I mean the
exterminator of the bed bug dog these
are all angles where it's like there's a
joke here there's a joke you could see
that there's jokes there I just haven't
uncovered them yet so it's like a
process and the reality of it is I have
one good joke so it's like okay let's
build from there but I don't want to
deceive myself it's like I guess I could
have five average jokes and one good
joke but that's not helping me at all
exactly yeah I talked to Ian Edwards on
here and he was talking about growing a
one-liner into like a fully functioning
bit and his process is like doing a lot
of research so if he does have like you
just said all those details about like
the the stomach and all that right
well there's research and it's also my
personal experience yeah flipping out
like I was trying to meditate through
this whole thing it's like I just
started meditation at the time it's like
that's yeah and then you're getting big
and then they attack one person out of a
out of an apartment full of people that
they could attack so you feel singled
out it's just you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of material there and so I
just haven't I haven't got it yet so
it's something that's the process you
keep working you keep asking questions
and then and then you might have
something from left field that you can
attach to oh this has nothing I didn't
think this had anything to do with
bedbugs but it does it has something to
do with what I'm talking about so then
you can connect it yeah I'm starting to
find that I've been doing this a little
over nine years and I'm I'm at a point
where I've been I mean I'm a laugh [ __ ]
I want like laughs laughs laughs laughs
laughs but it is at a point where it's
like okay they're laughing but they're
not connecting in terms of their it's
it's laughter brasonic memorable they
don't come up after it's like that's
just like my dad or whatever
so I'm now starting to be more mindful
about injecting my personal experience
into whatever it is and that takes
longer yeah well that's the maneuver I
made from one album to the other album
the first time was like a joke
I need a joke here I need a joke here I
need a joke on this topic and the next
album was like now this is gonna be
more personal because that matters that
makes a difference the personal I think
it does you know I mean like if somebody
can connect to you and you could take an
experience that we all have and you
could make that funny you know feelings
that we have this basically the same
feelings towards things well experience
anger happiness love you know and if you
could take that and put it in different
situations that we all experience and
relatable yeah that's better than
telling a joke that's just kind of a
standalone innocuous joke yeah it's
probably how you build a fanbase too
because they're more invested in you as
a person as opposed to just like a
talking funny man
right or woman or yeah like a joke
whatever yeah yeah I was feeling like a
joke machine for awhile it's like oh
this is you have this skills good you
know it's good to have this skill but
it's like now there's no reason you
can't take that skill and apply it in a
more personal way mm-hmm you know and
that takes up a little bit of loosening
up your process a little bit maybe your
free writing more than tweeting you know
I mean like up HOD cast helped me
because it helped me it helped me talk
about some of these issues in a free way
you know and just don't Yammer on about
a minute that actually does help yeah
and I know guys who do a podcast and
they cover topics on their podcast and
that's how they write basically by just
doing the topics first on their podcast
and then and then and then working those
topics and to the stage and it's more in
your voice because it was kind of
conceived in your voice right it's more
of a loose whereas like writing a joke
just sitting down and writing a joke
which is what I used to do is to sit
down and turn out jokes it's like not it
doesn't come off as organic as organic
you could take the idea and then you
know if you play with it and verbally it
helps but would you say it's important
for comedians starting out to first
understand how to create a joke like sit
down and create jokes and then once
you've accomplished that skill set then
you can start to apply it but it seems
like a lot of people are trying to
microwave their material now in terms of
like I'll just get up there with
attitude and I'll just get by but it's
like I mean there's got to be writing in
there yeah I mean when you're
starting on you're still trying to find
your voice and still trying to find your
way so I won't criticize any anybody
trying to do that of course but uh but
yeah content is important and we all you
know maybe the audience doesn't know but
we all know the comics know anybody
watching you knows who knows comedy even
a comedy fan the waitresses people who
see you all the time they know all of
our they know they can see through all
of our [ __ ] right it's more like you
know keep it to a minimal and try to try
to have content you're trying to go up
there and with jokes and you're trying
to go up there and say something you're
not just going up there with attitude
yes I mean I'm not some people do that
I'm just I don't happen to be a big fan
of that I happen to be more of a fan of
what the person is actually saying
content wise do they have a skill set
you know we can all kind of tell each
other's skill set on stage you know I
mean again you can see somebody and be
like all that person has a high skill
set or that person is good like it's
like they're this men you know they're
developing and they're good but they
have something we can all kind of see
that so you want to be one of those
people where it's like and you can go up
there with attitude you can go up there
with charisma and all that so I'm not
I'm not saying you but it's better if
you go up there with all that charisma
and attitude and have content and a
skill set of joke writing to go with it
yeah and I don't think like this is how
you should do stand-up some people start
with the writing and then grow in the
price some people start with the
performing and they're writing like I'm
by no means like this is how you do it
but it I have found I started out with
one-liners and that kind of helped me to
start thinking funny
yeah exercising my funny brain yeah and
now it's growing into more of like an
organic delivery yeah but that's just
that was from personal experience yeah I
was a ja you're right about that cuz
some guys have like an attitude and
charisma and the jokes come second and
they grow into the jokes
some guys are joke guys and they have to
grow into the performance aspect i was a
joke i growing into the performance
aspect yeah but i gotta say like now
like even in my development now I'm
enjoying it I'm enjoying the performance
aspect of it much more because I'm like
starting to let it go and starting to
have fun so if you're going that route
from jokes to performance it's like it's
important to realize that this
supposed to be fun yes right there and
you're already you already have the
jokes so just go up there and have I
find if you're having fun with yourself
up there and you you are playful with
the audience your joke writing will come
off much better you know watching
watching you live this weekend like when
you're talking you watch someone and
you're like oh okay there there's a
strong skill set they have like this was
a late show the it wasn't the best
audience in terms of response but one of
my favorite things is to watch a strong
comedian build an audience to them and
not go out and grab them right and you
you were so patient and so consistent
and so persistent in your delivery and
you didn't falter and you didn't break
out of it and be like well right guys
we're all here I mean you you literally
you just stuck to your rhythm and you
stuck to your material and you just
stayed in your pace and over time the
audience almost just started to kind of
like pulse to your beat and by the end
there's applause break yeah we're at the
beginning it was slow and steady and
then it crescendos into oh you got him
that's skill man well yeah if you're not
a name back first of all they don't and
it's not it's just kind of like a
scatterbrained audience like we had on
The Late Show they don't trust you first
of all cuz I don't know you so it's like
you have to gain trust that you're funny
and then yeah I find with that crowd
that specific crowd and there's a lot of
crowds like that you going out and doing
quickly they'll derail you if you give
them too much power they'll derail you
so cuz they're not a lot of them are not
comedy fans a lot of them are
disinterested in what's happening a lot
of them are not gonna get what you're
doing anyway but you still have to try
you can't [ __ ] on them too much and be
like you're no good you that oh it's no
I mean maybe wants to smack them into
line but after that it's like it you're
not helping yourself any by by downing
them it just it because the people who
are watching and listening and there
were some people in that crowd it makes
them feel like whatwhat am I doing here
I mean if this sucks if everybody if you
know if this sucks so it's like you just
keep you keep coming and you keep trying
to bring them in but you don't pander
and you don't give them the power like
you lead them mmm you know lead them and
that and that's a thing that you learn
from working working audiences like that
you know audiences where it's like some
people are comedy fans some people your
fans some people are comedy fans and
some people have went out on a date
night and got it all we got
got it completely wrong what they were
signing up for so you have to deal with
all that in a mix and the way to do that
is in that specific crowd was to keep
beating your drum and do it in a
positive way but don't give them the
power because they don't know the
audience they don't know mm-hmm Keith
don't give them the power like lead them
into what's funny well what's your
mindset at the beginning of that set
when you do a couple jokes and it's kind
of like oh okay like is it like one of
these or it's like no I'm gonna get them
like what is your mindset of like okay
I'm gonna have to go like 12 rounds on
this well it helps because I watch the
openers with now watching the Mercer
openers were very good
they're very good they're good comics so
I was watching them respond to the
openers and I was like okay this is this
is gonna be an uphill fight I know this
is gonna be tough uh-huh so I already
know it going up when when it's a
situation where it's a host and the
feature and then me I already can watch
and know that it's gonna be a log fight
so that helps because it's like okay I
know it's none of us it's them but
that'd be that as it may I still have to
go do my time so I'm gonna go and
there's a challenge to it too it's like
I think I can let me let me exercise
that muscle and let me see if I can get
them bring them in effectively and uh
you know obviously I'm not gonna you
know it's not gonna be a standing
ovation at the end but I'm gonna do the
best I can to work them and work them
and work them and it just takes
persistence over time and that's the
best way to deal with that audience
that's not an ideal situation but yeah
it's a good skill set to have because I
know guys who are really good joke
writers but that skill set has eluded
them I don't
you know everybody has different comes
up differently so when you have people
late and a drunk and they're not
listening to your great jokes and they
can't appreciate your great jokes you
need another level of skill to in order
to like bring keep bringing them in and
then keep hitting them with you and keep
bringing them in and keep hitting them
keep like beating your own drum in that
way so what do you mean like bringing
them in in terms cuz you would almost
have moments you're like alright fifteen
minutes in we're getting there is that
like a technique of like I'm starting to
bring them in is that what you mean by
yeah yeah like you're working guys it's
great we're gonna mean like I'm talking
them into it and and and you keep keep
working them and and that way because
there's people who paid and are
interested and and and are laughing so
you don't want to give it you don't want
to give the set over to the people who
made a mistake by coming there or like
them or not comedy fans you know I mean
they're you're gonna lose them anyway so
it's a mine as well like it's fine but
you want to you want to make sure the
people who came to see you or came to
see a comedy show and are into it get
what they came for
yes you just give it over to the
dum-dums then they hijack the show and
you're giving them the power to hijack
the show and the people who really came
to see or like this is this is what you
do on a in a live performance you know
and it's not that's not totally fall you
walk into a bad you know not a bad
situation we all walk into a tough
situation and you know but you have to
handle it
so that the people who came to see you
or are actually seeing anything what you
do you mentioned that even after the
show when we were talking is like I was
I was impressed with how you like worked
them in into your rhythm and you were an
even mentioned you're like well I knew
like the this couple here was into it
and like over here like you pointed out
every one that you had from the
beginning right and then from you just
kept focusing on them almost and it just
kind of spread through the audience and
then the people who weren't there were
two women who weren't into it at all and
they were interrupting like the earlier
acts and they kind of like peeled off
like one went to the bathroom for a long
then the other one came in and the other
one bet so they had nowhere to talk to
and that was because they kind of got
disinterested you know what was
happening it and these ladies there was
a group of ladies in the middle who who
were disinterested also I could see it
in their faces so they kind of went to
the bathroom and like they lost interest
in what was happening that's fine as
long as they're not the disturbance they
lost complete interest because then it
opens it up for the people who were
really paying it's and there were people
there who were paying attention or way
into it so yeah that's great yeah it's
good so when you're when you're
developing this skill a bombing is a
huge part of this and a question I ask
every comedian on here is like an epic
booze story or just a show they'll never
forget that just went completely off the
rails so what is what is yours that you
have it's not so much bombing it's just
a mistake I've made the mistake before
of of being in that same situation the
Friday night and having those people
attempt to hijack the show and catering
to them because I didn't want an ugly
confrontation or I didn't want I didn't
know how to do what I did
Friday night I wasn't experienced enough
to do what I did so so I I gave I'm just
looking for laughs so I just I kind of
like they were willing to enter Jack so
I would just go back and forth with them
and and let them hijack the show and
that's so not it's not bombing but it's
a mistake mm-hmm it's a mistake so I've
made that mistake before and afterwards
I'll be like yeah that didn't that I
shouldn't be letting that happen you
know I shouldn't be letting them hijack
the show and turning me into their thing
because I'm not a dancing monkey for
them so but it's like okay how could I
have done this better how could I have
done this differently you know when that
when that happens again how can I steer
the show and then if it comes to them
getting thrown out then they get thrown
out then well then I'll you know once
the awkwardness of that Panetti thrown
up and they get thrown out then I have
to like reset and start again and and
key and build build back and it'll
probably be better
if they're if they're out they're out of
the room but it's not so much bombing
it's it's making this making the mistake
of of letting people who are not
interested in the show hijack the show
yeah and and then just is just to just
to get out just to get out of there with
um you know without bombing so we've
been doing this almost twenty years so
what is you said coming off the coffee
yeah
anything else Joe if there's anything
else let me know that was the best
reaction the hotel coffee Joe you've
been doing this 20 years yeah man thanks
for the reminder thanks Joe
did you did you think what did you think
where'd you think your comedy career
would be in 20 years
I actually thought I yeah I had a vision
okay I was gonna move to New York and I
would either be a huge success and be
rich or I would be I would bottom out
and I would have to get a job that's
what I thought would happen and I didn't
never picture this weird in-between
phase where it's like you're working and
you're making money and it's been a
period of but that by no means happened
overnight that was years and years and
years of climbing and scratching but
good things have happened I've gotten TV
credits and been on done stand-up on TV
and kept turning but I just didn't know
I didn't see it I thought it would be
either success or failure success I'm
winning failure I lost and I'll get out
that's what I thought it was gonna be
but I didn't realize this in-between
phase where it's like you're gonna have
times where you're getting a lot and
people are really high on you and then
other times where people I want nothing
to do with you and it's got a lot to do
with what Hollywood like what the
industry is looking for at the time you
know and also your skill set not just in
stand-up but like in other things in
acting and podcasting it's like well
how's your skill level
but it has a lot to do also with what
they're looking for at the time but that
shouldn't what I've learned is you just
keep beating it just like in the set
beating your drum you keep coming keep
looking for ways to improve yourself and
that will separate you from the pack
almost staying consistent in your career
consistent but it's very easy I think I
said this on other podcasts in a
sarcastic way but it's real it's very
easy to become because the business is
not fair okay so it's very easy to like
feel cheated and to get better and then
to stop working the way that you should
be working so and I understand it I
understand the feeling but there's a
thing where it's like you can't let that
affect you can't let that overtake you
you can't let that dictate your daily
practice so even if nobody cares and
nobody's gonna give me anything and I'm
in a gutter like keep the practice keep
working and figure out another way to
rise
oh god this network doesn't want to give
it to me this network doesn't want to
give me anything it's like okay not the
end of the world I'll do it this way
I'll try this network I'll try this
network and if those networks don't want
it I'll put it on YouTube
I you know I had that with my album like
nobody wanted to give me a special and I
guess I could have shot a special myself
I've had friends who did that and that
was an option but I'm like now I'm gonna
put it on a CD and then I'll go around
to my friends podcast and how I'll plug
it and promote it and I'll have all the
material out I'll have it all documented
and I won't go with a label I'll go
myself and it worked out it worked out
great for me because now that is on
Sirius XM and it's being played and not
to mention the fact the most important
thing was that it's documented I have it
I have it down and now let's move on to
the next thing and you know what I mean
and so it's easy to let
it's easy to get bitter in those
situations but you have to stay strong
and consistent and believe in what
you're doing
you know it's it's very hard sometimes
though it is it is very hard so I
understand it I understand why people do
get better and get angry mmm and not to
mention your album I mean it was a one
album of the year for serious and
vulture ultra album of the year yes and
it's 90 minutes by the way
it's this is a complete body of work
yeah what made you what made you not
want to go the special route and just do
that it was it to save money or do not
see enough upside to investing that you
know the upside was there if I had to do
it over maybe I would just maybe I would
have taped it maybe I would have I would
have taped it and then put it on YouTube
right and then and then released an
album I probably would have done that if
I had to do it over but um I was like
where am I gonna where am I gonna sell
this what if nobody wants to buy it
what if I invest all this money and uh I
don't break even like what is the
what-ifs
but the most important thing is that
besides the money end of it is aside
from the money and I should say is that
it gets exposure like people or let
people listen to it I don't want to do a
special that no one watches so I think I
did the right thing in terms of putting
out an album because you know like a
podcast people can listen to it while
they're doing other stuff mm-hmm
so the only if I had to do it over I
would have brought in a film crew too I
would have hired my own
and I would have had it taped and then I
would have put it out on YouTube it's
good that's what I would have done
different because the audio was good and
the album has done well for me and
people have listened to it anybody has
listen to it's been good feedback but if
I would have had the video to it then I
would have both things available and I
would have been worth the money I think
it's just one more way for people to
find you right right and then and you
know and then there's the option now of
like I don't know how many people watch
an hour anyway of somebody who's not
famous so you take the hour and you you
cut it up into clips and then you put
that and you
you plug the clips it's like there's all
these different strategies on how to get
seen well that's the Andrew Scholes
model
yeah Andrews great he pretty much paved
the path for comics to just give him
give him almost give it out like like
like he modeled his after the music
business where he's like you just
release a single like yeah hit singles
and as we did with his jokes and now
it's unbelievable and it's I really he's
a friend of mine and but I really like
what he did I like the fact that that's
an example of a guy who was shut out of
doing stand-up on television yeah and he
was like no I'm not gonna take no for an
answer I know I have something good here
and and he found another way and there
are other guys like that and Andrews
like on the forefront of that so I think
all of us like admire that about him for
sure it's so interesting to be sitting
here as a comedian with with I mean with
no credits sitting here like really just
trying to build my own success right and
a lot of us comedians we see comedians
like you we're like oh man he is a
half-hour
I'm coming central he's been on Jimmy
Fallon and Conan he's done all this cool
stuff and and you're still sitting here
almost 20 years and you're like I'm
still trying to figure it out yeah I'm
so get every level yeah we think there's
the we're also gonna wake up one day and
have it figured out but every level
we're all just still trying to figure I
mean you could have outward outer levels
of success like a huge high level of
outer success where the world recognizes
you and goes you are like unbelievable
year that you're great so you could have
that but yeah at the end of the day were
I mean me personally I'm still trying to
improve and get better and figure it out
yeah are you working towards anything
like specific are you big on goals I
know you have an athletic background so
I didn't know yeah I mean I would like
to do more acting and but I would like
to do I would like to write something
other than stand-up whether it's a show
or or something I would like to take the
skills that I have and apply it to
something else
whether it's a web series or a show I
would like to
to try that and but I'm more excited
about like I think you know I can just
get better comedic ly you know first
album was good it's mostly a joke based
album and then the second album was I
think better more personal and like more
jokes and I think I can evolve I can
evolve to be better and that's exciting
to me like and taking the jokes and then
my stage presence getting better with my
stage presence and and little things
like slowing down or like setting the
joke up and a funnier way like uh you
know and still but while still writing
personal that is something I've heard
you say is you onstage you focus on
slowing down and smiling yes yeah
because I mean just from watching you're
watching my sets it's like sometimes
I'll just like commit to it and stay
straight face the entire time and it's
like that's it serves a purpose but also
like relaxing and laughing at your own
yeah I mean it's not a scripted thing
where you're I were to laugh here I'm
gonna enjoy here it's like but just
going up with a certain mindset like I'm
gonna have fun like I'm gonna have fun
no matter what I'm gonna have fun with
these jokes and the way I'm framing
stuff I'm gonna I'm gonna have fun with
it you know so but that's it's going up
with that mindset not with I used to go
up with a mindset like I'm gonna get
these jokes out I'm a with a crowd like
well they're not like me I'm gonna win
them over I'm gonna I'm gonna win them
over with these jokes now I don't have
that mindset anymore I go with the
mindset like I'm gonna have fun I have
the jokes I'm gonna work the jokes and
I'm gonna if you have fun they'll have
fun and are you telling yourself this
pre-show like are you running through in
your mind okay I'm gonna have fun with
this the audience is go I'm not fun I'm
not like that's part of it it's like if
you're doing that if you're like I'm
gonna have fun I'm gonna fun part of
like your nullifying it by it's just a
general attitude towards I you know but
it's like I've been headlining long
enough now to be like I know I have the
time
I know that even if all my material was
taken for my crowd work my way into like
the time you know I mean yeah it's like
relaxing that the best times I have
onstage when I'm relaxing I have new
material and I'm playing you're being
playful with it so I have a wrestling
background and I wasn't I was good in
high school but I was I got beat up in
college a lot and Penn State right now
into Penn State yeah you're legit
wrestler yeah well I mean I was over a
year but I learned they have a top
program now and I was asking one of my
friends who's a coach what they're doing
differently because they're like the
Iowa of the 80s now they're like they
win a national championship every year
they just keep putting out national
championships and I'm like okay it just
it's it's interesting to me what they're
doing different than maybe in Iowa or an
Iowa State or an Oklahoma State like
these are all top-tier programs so how
does Penn State separate itself or how
did the New England Patriots separate
themselves you know and he was saying
that their practices are obviously
intense and tough but there's when they
wrestle like there's a certain
playfulness in the way though wrestle
it's like not that they're not going
hard but they'll they'll try different
things like there's a looseness and a
playfulness in how they're drilling and
how they're going live wrestling live in
it and and that helps it helps if you go
in with the attitude it's like I'm just
gonna let it go and be envy instead of
this tense like I'm gonna I'm gonna go
in there and do it's like it doesn't
work as good if you're more playful and
open to possibilities a home wrestling
and and I find it on in stand-up to like
if you go up there loose and but you've
done your homework also it's not like
you're just going up there with your
charisma and no jokes and you're going
up there with your jokes but you're
going up there with the mindset it's
like I'm gonna be playful and I'm gonna
set this up this way and then it it's
it's a better result and you feel better
about it afterwards and almost fine
being open-minded on stage where like if
a joke leads you somewhere let it lead
you there and then you can come back to
the rest of it or like be open to a
flexibility and not just
word for word no I've gotta say this
right all right they're laughing too
long I'll just step on it to get this
and tag out like it's almost being a
little more fluid up there I guess fluid
and yeah naturally you'll have more fun
which takes time as well like a comedian
starting out you're like I'll just go up
and talk but it's like it takes years of
just living on stage right to have the
confidence and the even the awareness to
even listen to the audience and be like
timing the laugh to like let it live and
then kind of jump back in as it's coming
back down like that all takes time to
listen to and it's fun to hear I mean
I'm nine years in I'm by no means a
master twenty years and you're still
like I'm getting better and I'm still
learn to learning that's the that's why
I love comedy man yeah it's a thing but
I think it's a thing in like any field
like if I was like it's like carpentry
or any of the sounds like you have a
skill set that you can always improve to
become better like in any field that
you're in and the politics of your field
are probably much like the politics of
this which is like it's not fair and it
can be discouraging but as long as you
keep developing your skill set I find
that's what's most important
even if you're not a commercial success
people will be able to see you that's
the good thing about what we do it's
like people will be able to see you and
be like that's really good that's even
if it's like for a joke or something
like that's very very good you know
people will be able to see it even if
you get no credit for it so that's the
beauty of it no one can deny they can
deny you but you they can't deny what's
happening in the room they get an i it
so yes it's a good way to build like
everyone can build their own audience
now as well that's true yeah a lot of
things have opened up to where the these
gatekeepers don't have the power Andrew
Schultz is like a he's a testament to
that he's a guy would just you went out
and got his audience and you can do that
now you know it's not that's not easy to
do either so but that it's available
you know it's available and I like you
also you're not only focused on getting
better on stage but you focus on getting
better offstage with like you do you
exercise you do meditation and breathe
exercises like I think more comedians
could benefit from not only the care on
stage but also offstage I find if I feel
better if I feel better yes I'll perform
better I feel better I'll write more
effectively like I'll just you know if I
feel like garbage and I'm not gonna
write as well so the part of it is just
I mean it's good to live a healthy
lifestyle
anyway but part of it is if I feel good
then everything else will fall like I'll
write better I'll be a better I'll be a
better comic cuz overall yeah overall
I'll be better and the creativity goes
up like once you if you feel better your
creativity will be better mm and it will
flow so it's but if you feel like
garbage all the time and I you know at
least that's the way the way I feel
maybe some people are fueled by that but
I'm not like I'm a guy like if I feel
good my creativity gets ratcheted up if
I feel terrible it kills it so oh yeah I
was just I was just featuring in
Chattanooga and I went out my wife went
up with me I had I don't even really
drink that much but we were out I had a
beer at noon that night both those shows
were not great because I was just like
there was just something off all right
I'm just I was just and I told her I was
like I'm gonna go and bomb tonight I
didn't like bomb but it's like I bomb
for me like in our head it's like every
shows gone great but you can feel it too
it's like oh that made me sluggish yeah
I may not that didn't grow in me or
anything but it didn't help
it didn't add to anything but yeah yeah
you learned that after a while too it's
like oh I'm not gonna day drink then
like if I have shows like I'm not gonna
day drink if I'm working on if I'm
working on something and it's always a
good to go up you know it's always good
to go up with some kind of a plan oh but
the one I want to work on this stuff it
doesn't have to be a hard core this then
this then this it's like I'm gonna go up
there with a plan you know like to work
on I'm gonna work on this or even if
you're not working on jokes I'm gonna
work on slowing down I'm gonna work on
enjoying myself morons like there's
other things to work on whoo that's gold
gold you almost develop a skill like one
at a time where it is like okay
I'm gonna focus on slowing down this
month I'm gonna focus on standing still
I don't do one at a time I do I'm gonna
go up and have a good time but I want to
work on material so I'm gonna go up and
and have a good time but I also would
like to work on this material that's new
and not totally formed yet so I'm gonna
be playful with it but as I'm doing that
I'm going to have fun with the crowd I'm
gonna have fun yeah I can always bring
it back to jokes if I need to mm-hmm so
I'm gonna go up and have be playful and
have fun do you find breathing being
remembering to breathe onstage helps
with like slowing down and being more
playful like remembering breathing but I
think I find being in the moment helps
okay
if you're not so much in your head and
you have confidence it's a confidence
issue to which I had poor confidence at
the beginning but it's a just to sit to
sit in the silences sometimes like I had
a real issue with that first which is
why I was writing so intensely to try to
make it so that everything is a laugh
and at the end of the day that's you
know that's good but it's also I looked
at it and I'm like oh that's because of
stage fright really is because I I
didn't have the eye I couldn't sit in a
silence so you know recognizing that and
then oh you know you know working on it
between the jib but you you're the one
controlling it it's not a silence that's
not expected you're leaving space and
then there's a silence and then you get
into the next thing it's like you're
orchestrating it it's not just happening
to you you know but even if they even if
it is it's like even if it does happen
to you then it's like standing strong in
the moment and and confidently moving
forward that's something a lot of comics
struggle with especially early on is
standing in that silence just yeah and
some people have a great ability to do
that and some and and some people don't
so it's something to work on but it's
not being afraid of it Zordon so even if
if you were to comics to help work on it
is it almost
there is a silence and just stand in it
even longer than maybe you think you
should just to get comfortable in that
space I mean it'll happen naturally okay
it'll happen naturally but also like
maybe you you want the silence like are
you like you create it you create it and
then go into another joke but yeah it
helps to be in the moment it helps to
stay in the moment and not to panic some
people have good poise yeah in the
moment and some people don't and you
know but even if you don't like you
commit something to work on you can work
on it and I wasn't I wasn't good and
I've worked on it and now it's like I'm
not I'm not as afraid of it and I'll
even create silences sometimes to to
have the next thing pop harder oh how
will you do that
well I mean it just depends it depends
on how the flow is it's like you'll say
something say something say something
right before the punch line you'll take
a take a small silence and then hit with
the punch line hmm and and it'll be a
bigger pop than if you just ran it
together
boom yeah that little pause yeah all
right well that's not really sitting in
silence more of applause but I guess it
goes sometimes that sometimes you could
be too nervous to take that pause you
know and since in controlling the tempo
instead of letting it control you
that's really what I'm trying to say I
probably said it in a very muddled way
but that's really what you're this is
over get it out of here yeah we're over
this is it you know the final thing I
wanted to ask you is your most epic bomb
story or most epic have you ever been
booed on stage before yeah epic what's
an epic one there's a couple as a couple
I have most recent one was that a
private oh gosh it was a prize already
yeah it was for cops but it was saddest
for like it was a company that sold
bulletproof vests
and holsters like it's not guns with
stuff for law enforcement officers and
my friend who booked it was trying to
tell the guy who was in charge look they
have to be seated and I have to be
paying attention and you know they
everybody has to be seated in paying
attention they can't be eating or
getting drinks and the guy was like
we're fine he wasn't listening
and at the end my buddy was like okay
either you either I have to take this
the way that he wants to do it or just
leave it and there was money involved
obviously so he did it and he went up
and and struggle and I went up and just
it's because I don't know if it was a
bomb but like there was some people it
was a high ceilings it was it was in a
club so people who were sitting in this
circular thing but everybody was at the
bar having drinks he didn't stop
anything
so my jokes were just going and some
people would laugh but I couldn't hear
them laugh and it would just be more
talking so it was number one a long
period of time I had to do because there
were no laughs coming back and it was
brutal and I got a safe here I was
fuming I was really mad but I said if
that guy you know if there was any
whatever I mean I that was not pleasant
how far into your career it was a reason
it was this year
who's this past year yeah whoo yeah it
was not good I was not happy with it
because that's kind of I mean I'll take
a responsibility for a bomb if it's my
fault but you know if you set it up for
me to fail
like then that's I mean that's not my
that's not on me you done correctly so
but my friend is a good he knew
he's a good guy and he tried but the guy
wasn't trying to hear and it's like okay
well I guess we'll just no one will have
a good time then and we'll take your
money I don't know like no one will have
a good time and we'll take your money
like what you want like that what you
want to do this the best way so
everybody wins but you want to do it so
everybody loses I guess I guess
everybody will lose then you know so so
that's what you want your comedy show to
be okay everyone look imagine everyone
to lose because you know more guys like
don't know me it's always the guys like
they
call you and they go okay here's what
we're gonna do dude we're gonna have an
emcee then we're gonna have a band and
then we're gonna have a comic and then a
band and then a comic no one's gonna be
sitting down everybody's gonna be
roaming around getting cocktails and
chatting what do you think it's like are
you out of your mind you know comedy
look you have to tell them how Comedy
Works like they know that you have to
sits not music you have to sit there you
have to pay attention food can't be
being served like you can't have any of
that it's got to be focused and and if
it's a problem make the conflict the
comic can do less time or don't have a
comic that's also an option it doesn't
sound like you want to have a comic we
want to have it we also want to band
then somebody who juggles it's like you
have to and then you have to like the
person has to be sitting focused and
paying attention period yeah period all
right well Mike Becky owned this I'm
sorry I yelled no this thing it's as we
worked up to it you're very very
soft-spoken go yeah but we crescendo it
into it like like the shows you know
they you leave them leave them laughing
and leave an applause so before we get
out of here is there anything else you
want the world to know now buy my album
but where it's kind of thoughtful the
worst kind of thought was kind of
thoughtful available on iTunes and if
you could follow me on social media a
comic like video I would appreciate it
thank you all right and your podcast my
podcast is no come on Mike no disrespect
on the gasps digital network and
available on iTunes and also on YouTube
so no disrespect all right Mike Beck um
thanks for being on hot breath my man
thank you thanks for having me Joel did
you have fun yeah it was great you
enjoyed it yes we really really aired
out a lot of things that were inside of
me hey that's what we're doing here
we're trying to do this for for comics
buy comics you know okay all right well
maybe the last thing all the comics do
on here is they just look into the
camera let them know who you are and why
they should listen to hot breath
I'm Mike lucky own and you should listen
to hot breath because we had a very nice
conversation about stand-up comedy so if
you're interested not interested in
stand-up comedy and I'm just one man
who's had certain experiences turn into
hot breath thank you for having me
all right all right Mike Vecchio thanks
buddy thank you and that water's for you
too oh yeah that water was for you
[Music]